was kind of rough i had an awful battle
the doctor set my parents down and said
my life was fragile perspective is the
game
i guarantee the name just put your head
down do the work and everything will
change
sympathy helping fields yeah that's what
i wanted be a patient hello
[Music]
july 17 2020
i believe that 2020 has the potential to
be a second half team
and it's been rough for some folks um
but
one steps backwards one step backwards
three steps forward
really excited about this show big shout
out seth get in here let me say hello to
you
glad you're here morgan who uh who uh
produced my podcast for years went to
vayner talent now back on team gary
we're jamming making sure he knows how
to produce these uh shows not the
hardest thing right seth
that's awesome yeah it's a little more
it's all me right like dustin should
deserve
no credit dustin i think you're here too
shadowing get in here so i could just
make fun of you
you did nothing dustin well yeah i know
other other than like every literally
caster and mott
on wine library tv india and stunwin
on askgaryvee like basically i have a
real knack for
making sure that the the uh the other
person
gets more credit than i do which you
know i think is
incredibly kind of me dustin i've made
you a international superstar dust
and now seth look how handsome seth is
dust that's a problem for us
yeah he's free it's true yeah all right
get out of here let's get into this show
all right
let me say hello real quick actually
seth let me say hello get out of here
son
jimmy peters good to see you big ups
fazonj what's up natalie sanchez
big ups everybody who is part of the
share squad
let's grab these urls right now do not
be selfish share the show
share the show share
the show oh i see paul talking about
buying some trading cards in there i've
been like on fire with trading cards
we'll have to do another all trading
card show let's make sure we get that
but who's part of the share squad if
you've shared the url
let me know big shout out to the uk 2 am
to 2 pm excuse me in the afternoon right
in the middle of the day ginger's in the
building
kudan is in the building ken wright ken
white in the building excuse me jacob
sure
from japan big ups big ups to linkedin
crew i just saw like 15 links
in a row where's the twitch squad vayner
gaming's in the building
now so tomato tomato bryson
share squad go to the url you're on
right now if you're watching on facebook
just hit that share button if you're
watching on periscope hit that share
button
who is on the share squad is what i want
to know all right let's get going
what's good bro yo well anytime i got an
opportunity to surprise you i'm gonna
take advantage
i'm with you i'm fired up taylor's good
to see you outside
i am outside it's gonna rain in a second
so i'm gonna have to run inside but
how you doing how you feeling great man
good good
man settling in you know i gotta just
have a new baby boy so
congratulations mazel tov baby that's
amazing appreciate that i got two of
them now so
you know uh my wife now now it's divide
and conquer
yeah yeah right and if you get to three
it's zone defense so
make sure you keep your strategy up on
that
definitely i mean we got the toilet
seats we just keep them up i'm gonna
wait until they grow into that
get the strategy just going the
atmosphere
so what's up what can i answer for you
what's in your mind yo what's up my guy
um you know i think the question that i
had
um and it's something that i've worked
on for a long time but in your business
um i've been a huge fan of how you've
always
um kept your ownership of your business
no matter what you're getting into
um and i think that not just in the
music industry but probably for
a lot of us that are growing up we want
to know
how do you keep ownership of your
business still build your brand and
still work with other companies
the the reason i've been able to do what
i've done is i've left
short-term money on the table
to have the long-term ownership you know
it's not super complicated you know
like in music like in a lot of things
there's been a lot of times
i mean i've been offered some really
like game-changing
you know real money to give up things i
mean
i've i've already been approached to
kind of get into that you know shaq
michael jackson realm where like people
are like yo i'll just buy out you
and it's like real money um and
for me it's just i'd i'd rather
have far less money but have creative
control
i'm about playing the way i want to play
more than like me chasing buying the
jets
is much more fun than when i own them
and so and so if you're lucky and
or thoughtful whichever one this is
about realizing oh i'm about the game
game game game game for real
and of course it'd be nice that there's
some good things along the way
but i will never ever give up
being able to play pure for
a lot of money up front because a i
think i'm talented enough
to play pure and get more money it just
might take me 40 years
instead of 4 or 14 to me it's been about
the incredible lack of and the reason i
talk about patience and the reason i
talk about not keeping up with the
joneses and the reason i talk about
don't listen to other people is because
when your world is
quiet it can be the way you want it
yeah i love that like that's that's
beautiful
yeah no definitely man i can super see
that and i feel like
um especially you know in the music
industry an example is you know in 2016
i came out as you know openly bisexual
and the next project that i put out was
called be yourself and it was kind of uh
a stand
front on the idea but if i showed you
the cover i don't know if you ever saw
it
you'd probably think it's a little kind
of funny it's like me and these rainbow
tiny whities
i saw it i remember it okay you saw it
i'm letting you make sure everybody
knows but i know it
right thank you man i appreciate it uh
one thing that i always tell anybody any
artist that you know i have a
conversation with is
i can almost bet my last dollar that if
i had signed a deal back in
who says i mean maybe 2016 2015
there's no way that even if i had come
out to the community
there's no way that anybody that had
creative control which is what i
essentially give up every rapper
artist as you know gives up when we sign
these crazy deals
there's no way they would have let me
put that project out that no shot
been my my most successful
um because it was because it was so real
it was so honest exactly
and that story right there
i always say to every artist imagine how
many other artists just have ideas that
they never get to put out
you know what's funny if you want if you
want to be good
you copy what's popping right like it's
why so many young women
are getting plastic surgery lips and ass
whatever if you want to be good
you follow what's working right like you
come out with use the same terminology
wear the same clothes you put out the
same stuff you follow the same process
if you want to be good you you fast
follow what's already working
but you have zero originality which
means you've ceilinged
yourself you're in a ceiling now of good
for me i'd rather lose and die
but go for great with going with purity
and really what i'm about like so many
people right now hitting me up and be
like yo you got to
check off this sports card thing it's a
little corny i'm like [__]
you're corny
like like i i fight back like like you
know like cool kids are like yo
this is a little corny i'm like [__]
you're corny [__] you i don't listen to
you and by the way
i'm screen shooting this because in
three years you're gonna be flexing with
like brawn rookies on [__] tick tock
and i'm gonna laugh at you because i'm
gonna send this out to the world like
you have to live in your [__] cocoon
yeah definitely man
honestly the answer to the question is
patience patience
giving up money leaving money on the
table every year
to make more every decade would you say
that's betting on yourself
i would i would also say it's happiness
you know like
for me i just want to be happy like i'm
bro
the amount of money i've left on a table
between my partnership with my dad and
my brother
the amount of money i've left on the
table out of just kindness like
sometimes writing a check just out of
altruism just want to make that person
feel good
knowing i'm going to lose that money
like it's just not about the money for
me
a i'm talented enough to make it i
always was so of course i'm gonna have a
different relationship with it than
somebody who doesn't know how to make it
really needs it so
i don't i don't say that lightly but
it's just the truth of my reality
which then stumbled into me realizing oh
wait a minute
why am i so much happier than all these
friends around me that have so much more
oh it's because i play for the game and
they're playing for the lambo to show
the people because they've got
insecurities and they need that lambo to
get the girl
or to show the kid that picked on them
in sixth grade that look you know for me
i i'm flexing by being happier than the
next person
yeah i love that i love that priceless
taylor i'm looking forward to really
chopping proper at some point i know
we've been
going back at it so talk soon thank you
man talk to you soon
talk to you soon peace out man yeah
don't try to prove to your sister who's
more successful or your aunt
or your best friend that you you don't
rag yourself into the ground trying to
get that money to like buy a house to be
like see i'm good too
show them that you're happier than them
that's the ultimate [__]
chess move happiness
what the [__] you think we've been doing
here for three months in team with
garyvee it's all one big [__]
you know infrastructure one-man show
with incredible people behind him an
incredible community with william jordan
amanda smith
and north new jersey real estate and
towards la la land and garrett glenn one
incredible community
one show one man that's really trying to
hack it
get [__] happy on your terms don't
hear
anything it's [__] silence in this
[__]
it's [__] silence in this [__]
[__] cheer squad where you at how the
[__] are you not letting your friends
watch this right now they're watching
some dumb [__]
some news that's making them anxious
[__] getting scared some dumb [__]
get them on this [__] share this right
now
don't be selfish karma wins share this
[__] right now
let's keep it moving
cat
hi cat hi how are you
i'm amazing absolutely amazing the
perfect segment
i was just i'm incredibly happy
and it's i i in a huge part to you
i mean this has changed my life
that makes me happy you're chopping a
little bit so
i'm i'm nowhere i'm doing survival
training and i'm in the middle of
nowhere
i love it so i hear you so you're
lagging behind so like why don't you
ask away and i love your blue hair and
and i'm so happy to see you
i'm so happy to see you okay so i
i just have something for you um please
you've been
you've been more than a mentor you've
been a guardian
an earth angel sent to dive into the
trenches to show the rest of us the way
a kind being who selflessly gives to the
depths of his soul
so others can prosper and be free
unlocking cages and smashing old dogma
to transform this planet into a place of
honor
gratitude and kindness
gary you are a true gift
and a shining light that burns brightly
for others
to find their way garyvee you're the
bee's knees
you're very sweet that's an incredible
poem thank you for sharing that that
made me feel so so nice
really um the reason i wanted to share
that with you
is because um i want everybody to know
this isn't just about
making money and this isn't just about
changing your life
because of you i started tick tock um
i started one in december and i started
a new one in february and the one in
february is the one that's kind of
taken off and i had a woman a girl
a young girl that wrote me that said um
she was thinking of
jumping off a bridge and because she
watched one
one-minute tick-tock of mine she changed
her mind
and that's because of you um
it's literally because you put yourself
out there and you challenge people to
challenge themselves
i literally i mean i've i've worked in
hollywood i grew up in southern
california i worked i've worked with
celebrities a lot of my life
i've had a lot of money i've made six
figures selling real estate
for 12 years i was one of the top five
percent of realtors i could
be doing have lived in germany for two
years i was in the air force
i literally have traveled the world i've
done everything
and i'm happier right now
just being me doing survival training
um making these these videos and these
tick tock tick tocks and inspiring
people
to these these levels and
honestly i i i'm a gypsy by blood
it's in you
i'm tripping it's so good to have you on
here
yeah i really appreciate your your
energy is so like
lovely i really it's a really this is a
really great morning so far
thank you
don't cry don't cry
[Laughter]
please don't no is there is there any
question you have you're being
you've been very smooth okay
when you're at this level it's good to
hear that you know you make a difference
and you are
saving lives
[Music]
her
i mean the community that it's been
created
i mean i'm doing this warrior train
program and again this is all because of
you
this is all getting out of um this like
this a whole bunch of stuff that i went
through last year business it doesn't
even matter but just
just any [__] that could hit the fan
master
and so i i just changed my whole life
and it's because
honestly i would say it's like 9.7
because of you i'm just grateful
okay i'm so grateful and and the best
part is it's because of you
thank you for being on so let's move on
because it's too choppy but we'll have
cat back on
cat thank you so much like first of all
it was really cool big shout out to daft
punk
being on the show as well during that
moment um kat
you know what's great is i love being a
spark
but just so everybody who's watching
this that come on here or if you're
thinking it and saying
gary this because of you it just really
isn't it's because of you there's a lot
of people that watch me
i've i've had tens if not hundreds of
millions of people have come across me
at this point
but it's only thousands that go and
execute and that means it was
in you and so you know that that excites
me that excites me to like kind of like
sometimes tug on someone's shirt and say
hey
remember you got this and it's early it
can't i think one of the big things for
you me people in their 40s people in
their 50s 60s i think one of my
most important observations is that time
is
your friend more than you realize like
there's just a lot of people who are
giving up who are 42 47 53 they just
think it's over and just
it's just really not let's keep it
moving
how are you i'm good i just wanted to do
this
[Music]
i wanted to make it super loud but the
last it made me cry
that lady was sharing she was amazing
what's your name what's your name
i want to pronounce the problem my name
is
i'm from a yeah i'm from a state called
kerala in india
um yeah i make uh i make content on
youtube
and instagram like till i meet you after
that it's on across all platforms
so i have a small youtuber and lovely
instagram family they might be watching
now
so my parents so so yeah so oh my god
i'm missing out
i've prepared this but i'm missing it
out so get uh
don't worry i'm not here yeah yeah so my
content is basically
on my struggles with you know depression
anxiety and
yoga program called inner engineering
which i did which you know transformed
my life
so i have a question for you so can i
take just two minutes to give the
context before i ask
yes you can my friend yeah yeah so like
from my childhood like
i i was diagnosed with depression and
anxiety and
i was given prozac it's all often all
these medications i know it helps a lot
of people but it didn't help me
my brain got zoned out seizures side
effects but i took it for four years and
luckily
after that i met a psychologist who
helped me taper it off
but still i was a super miserable person
i was doing a master's in psychology but
i wanted to help people come out of
their depression but i was still super
miserable
i was in search of that happiness but it
was so so hard like i
tried everything out like at that time
yoga was something that i was like okay
this stuff just doesn't work but i was
like what the hell anyway things are not
working
yeah so i just went for this and boom
something just happened within me and uh
i was so grateful for just being alive
like you just say like just waking up in
the morning and being alive
that happened and then i thought this
needs to happen to more people
so i had a youtube channel till then so
i used to put more regarding men's style
and all but it wouldn't give me
happiness i was trying to extract
happiness out of it
but this was something that touched me
and i you know put out content genuinely
talking about rather than pushing
anything about my depression and these
things
and in from where i come from this is a
bit hard because if you talk about
depression and taking medications
yeah so maybe job no marriage you know
what
happened so there was no support as such
but still i just did it because that was
my truth at that time
and it just connected with people so for
one and a half years and you also had no
choice right you finally
you finally found something this is my
friend this is why it's so important to
listen to yourself
you grow up in a society in a framework
in a family that maybe this is not
acceptable or
or there's a stigma but you finally
found something that made you happy
just like kat pryor she's found these
tick-tock videos that made her happy
like the the answer is always the thing
that makes you happy it is always the
answer
people are always like oh i love this
but i won't have money or
i can't have children or i'll never
travel or my parents
[__] all that the only answer is the
thing that makes you happy
keep going yes yeah so i was putting out
content on youtube on instagram for like
one and a half years it was reaching
people and i was like i'm doing good
till i found your podcast and that free
deck you have put out there like taking
content from youtube then putting on
snapchat i'm like what the hell why
didn't people
talk about this earlier and why is this
stuff for free they should be charged
so then i started doing that i started
doing tick tock snapchat linkedin
i like everywhere i started posting my
content so people used to tell me like
tick tock is for kids why why are you
doing that i'm like gary we say sir i
don't care i don't think [__] come after
five years
but what happened is recently where i am
what the hell and then but recently uh
instagram has come out with a feature
called
reel which is similar to tick tock so my
question so my question is should i go
all out on real just like i went out on
tick tock
and also as i'm watching whether it's
dubsmash
or or triller or i saw something
yesterday headline i'll read it this
weekend another app that's just in
india that's similar you know there's
always going to be the next app
sometimes it's something as crazy as a
major geopolitical issue between india
and china
that takes away the platform other times
people
vine sells to twitter and it changes and
that goes away other times
snapchat's a rocket ship instagram a
competitor makes stories
it declines you know there's a million
reasons why a platform can change
but you may everyone's like gary see
what happened in india
all those people are [__] up like
they're not [__] they built an audience
on tick tock for that year
and then when it moves they can move
that audience to the next thing because
nobody's on tick tock it's not like
if tick tock disappeared from today it's
not like tick tock just disappeared for
me or charlie
right or somebody else it's or spencer x
it's that it disappeared for everybody
that attention goes somewhere else
we've built brand on that platform and
that audience finds us
on the next thing yeah right yeah so i
have one more question like i get a lot
of dms like people personally share so
i have to spend a lot of time answering
that but somewhere waiting spend putting
out content and answering to dm how
would you like
like eventually eventually the dms
decline
you know like i in 2007 to 2011 i
replied to every tweet i got
all of them 100 okay now it's not even
i'm not nowhere close it's so difficult
because the math takes over and you just
run out of time and you're just one
human being and i would never let
somebody answer
on my behalf nobody on my team it's
always me and so
and that's okay life evolves you know
that you know you just keep trying as
long as you don't abandon it i still
reply
every single day to one to 30 people and
uh
and i think it's important to give back
to your community okay thank you so
one final request like we had made some
memes my teammate uh
uh so for you if you could check it out
it would really mean the world to me
of course it's on my instagram handle at
y290
all right first of all i'm following you
back oh look at this look at this
guys i've always wanted to chill with
elephants
yes let me like that let me i'm going to
share this in my story my
friend oh there you go you're welcome
you're welcome
thank you so much 6200 people let's see
if the vayner nation can get you to 10
000. everybody go follow everybody go
follow this
extremely lovely man right there right
there right there
62 333 thank you
you got it my brother we'll go look at
it in a little bit all right transform
my life
thank you you're welcome my friend i
love you bye-bye let's keep it moving
great vibe what a good that's what
happens when you find happiness
jj what's good what's up man how you
doing
good morning to you good morning to you
where are you from
i'm from pennsylvania but i'm actually
living in san diego so i'm up really
early right now excuse me i expect it
i respect it that's you you look great
for 6 24 in the morning
i couldn't pass up the opportunity to
talk to you so thank you man what's
cooking
so i just had a question on like um just
your opinion on
when you go to a point with business
because uh i'm into a business for like
four years now
i started myself from the ground up with
like no money
um i run it from home as you can see
like the shipping stuff in the
background
i noticed that so i'm on that grind life
and i'm uh
i think i'm just like reaching a point
where a little bit burned out i need to
hire once
people and stuff yeah and i'm kind of
wearing all the hats so i was like
wondering like your opinion like how do
you navigate that like where do you
look for like hiring on people and uh
um do you need them to be physically
with you
uh kind of because i mean it's an
excitement yeah the ecommerce business
yeah let's go through the steps i
figured that was the case we're talking
san diego
or pennsylvania yeah san diego cool well
first of all
there's a lot of young hustlers right
now that probably want to learn to flip
life the ecommerce life
this dropship life vote so there's your
instagram handles
i think you'll probably get three to
nine people dming you that live in that
area
that may want to come and help look i
think craigslist i think social media
posting
i think emailing all your current
customers i think like
job boards like you know indeed like
it's really kind of that simple i think
the bigger question i don't think
it's where to start to find people i
think the answer is which
hires are best first yeah exactly
because i'm like doing the um
i think the number one thing that
everybody who's watching right now
should consider to hire first
is the thing that they need to take a
step back get honest as [__] with
themselves and say
what do i like the least
and or what do i like the least and i'm
at the worst
and i'm the worst at i would rather you
pick something that you like the least
over something you're at the worst at if
there's something that you like
very little and you're bad at it then
it's a home run
i mean you know look just like just like
i did at wine library
i used to pack every single order that
went out to online
all of them that's what i'm doing i'm
like actually making my product too so
it's like
a lot of work too because i'm getting to
a point where you can't
the facebook ads are working and stuff
you can't do logistics
yeah you have to do the ads and the and
the making it sounds like
but you can't be packing and shipping
and tracking and customer service
yeah because i would say i got to a
point to where i can't even like
i mean i know it's probably an excuse to
you but like you can't
you know what's so funny it's not an
excuse like i want you to make content
and to your point if you're packing
shipping making customer servicing
you're going to run out of time for that
yeah it's not an excuse it's a miss
strategy execution
you need to hire somebody yeah that's
the right for minimum wage by the way
you just need somebody boxing and
packing
sure yeah we're not we're not hiring
somebody for a hundred thousand a year
we're giving some kid in a bad situation
or somebody who needs a little side cash
or a youngster who wants to siphon and
learn and in four years do what you're
doing and you're happy for him you're
not
insecure you're like yeah i'm gonna i'm
gonna pay you 12 bucks 15 bucks 20 bucks
an hour or whatever it is
but you're gonna learn from me and in
two years you're gonna step away and do
your own version
like you know there's people always like
you're not paying them enough i'm like
you're [__] entitled you're like my
kids that grew up rich
i grew up with [__] i was thrilled to
make two bucks an hour
yeah there's a lot of immigrants poor uh
shitty households uh need some side cash
for a vacation
people that just like to work people
that like to learn by getting paid
instead of paying a university a lot of
money and getting debt and learning jack
practical [__] like there's a lot of
different ways to live life
yeah that's true bro you need to you
need to hire somebody to [__] do [__]
you don't want to do
i mean it also feels kind of lonely so
how would you think about um now we're
really
getting into it uh you know adding like
a business partner or someone
just because i wouldn't right away kind
of scary
well that's different lonely no because
then [__] packing pat is your friend
and you know just like i need dustin and
and seth right like i
that i don't think is the reason to if
you're saying you're concerned and how
to
navigate to the next level the answer is
it's worth a debate
i will tell you that seven out of ten
times it doesn't work out
at all and you gave up fifty percent or
twenty percent of something for no
reason
so you gotta think that through you
gotta think that through
um you know for me for me
i think that you need to first try to
have an employee
who might bring you value and i think
that you need to understand that
navigating doesn't need to be scary
because if you make the wrong decision
that's good let me see
one more time a learning experience
correct bro everyone's like oh [__] i
would
yeah i've been following your content
for a while so i know you know
it's like i didn't know [__] i just
navigated i went with intuition
i ended up being talented so a lot of
times it was right but plenty of times
it was wrong bro
yeah i've given up equity for no reason
i've
i've overpaid people for no reason i've
you know been somebody's psychiatrist
while they were my employee for no
reason i've done a ton of
wrong [__] we all do
yeah i don't like that you bring in
somebody
that you probably think is gonna like
know what to do when they don't know
what to do either regardless if they're
older and done
successful things you know this business
way better than anybody
hire hire an employee asap
okay okay esap ferg all right
all right bet see all right thank you
man you got it brother take care
hey what's up gary what's good sean
uh nothing much i'm super excited to be
on the show yesterday i was
supposed to be on but you had some great
uh
thank you other people on so i enjoyed
it a little about me
i'm 28 years old in south florida uh you
see i'm i'm heavily tatted
for being young um i have a physical
tourette so i'm like
the perfect storm of a person uh
and i'm so i'm a real soul i'm a realtor
in south florida
being a young realtor in south florida
having tattoos in it and having a twitch
is a big stigma
there's times where i go show houses and
they're like um
where's the agent of course that's
so that that happens to me a lot my uh
my question is
i mean you know south florida you've
done the agent 2020 2021 down here
my biggest thing is how do i stand out
being me in an oversaturated market
because
by realizing the thing that you're
worried about is your [__] strength
what do you what do you mean you stand
out naturally bro you're tatted up
young as [__] and have a twitch
listen real carefully to me right now
that's your strength
not your vulnerability
because sometimes i want it i want to
take advantage of it but i don't want to
i guess i don't want to market myself as
as
that i want to be able to people to see
me as i get that
i'm not asking you to like be like like
a circus promoter and be like come and
see the freak [__] like i'm not talking
that [__]
you're gonna stand out naturally if you
go straight as an
arrow you're already unique and stand
out
if you go completely robotic to try to
fit in and be respected you're still
going to stand out
that's your strength
so what would you say to so what would i
say i would say
i would say to put out good information
about the market
half the 80 percent of people are like
i'm not going to [__] with this guy he
scares me he looks different
20 are gonna [__] love you like i
would hire you way quicker than i would
hire
jane on the [__] bench ad in her
[__] suit
that's and then they'll build a book of
business
you're 28 you're [__] young build a
book of business with a 20
they will become word of mouth and
you'll build a business
the punchline of what i'm telling you is
don't overthink
your uniqueness and don't underestimate
it
it is what it is you're not going to
change bro
i was on the floor at a wine store more
knowledgeable than 99
of the wine people in america but
because i was 22 when i looked 16
half the people in my store even though
i grew up in that store for eight years
didn't
literally would look at me and i would
say can i help you and be like yeah
where
where's the wine that's me they're like
yeah they would walk out
i mean that happens i've had times where
like someone who's doubled my age
doesn't know half the knowledge that i
know and like i'll lose a client because
of that
i mean i'm not going to say it doesn't
get to me sometimes but i mean
i mean bro it got to me every time every
time
a stuck-up couple came in and didn't
want to listen to my wine advice
and walked out or worked with somebody
else it bothered me every time i was
happy they were doing business with my
dad's store
but every time my confidence my
competitiveness was like yep
let me just drop a little another drop
in this [__]
bucket of [__] demolishing the world
like
it became a motivator but i mean it
never
made me here's the key and this is the
plinko board of life
[__] [__] hits the fan somebody says
you suck
somebody picks wine somebody hires an
agent twice your age every time that
happens there's only one of two things
that people react to
either they get get into a mindset of
dwelling
and feeling bad for themselves and they
think it's an indicator that they suck
or they get [__] motivated and on
fire and think it's the other person
that sucks
i got lucky that i was number two i'm
trying to get everybody that's in bucket
number one
over to this number two side
i feel that in a lot of the stuff you do
that i'm like
my knuckles like it says grateful
tattooed on my knuckles
i had patience tattooed on me so a lot
of i mean i've been following for years
a lot of the stuff that you try to
engrave into people has been on my body
to
make myself remember and even like one
of the i mean
i'm big into like cards and stuff i just
you got bigger sports cars
like one of my ads just you know it's
like oh do you you know yu-gi-oh
yeah of course i don't know i don't know
that set well but i remember how huge it
was
in that era so there's uh there's yugi
and he's holding a card like a picture
i literally had my friend make myself
look like a yu-gi-oh card
and it looks like he's holding me as a
yuyok card and i posted that as an ad i
knew
i'm not gonna get the 40 to 50 but i
know i'm gonna get the people my age
from 20 to like 35 and it's been doing
well
and like for me doing that like putting
my own character out there it has helped
him
i said before more i mean a lot of my uh
it's i mean i
definitely do need to push a lot more i
do hold back because sometimes
you're holding back because you're it
makes all the sense in the world
you know what what it's like to let me
phrase you know what it's like to grow
up as a child
with a condition that is not hidable
yeah it's stigma for days yeah
bro we all everybody watching right now
grew up between first and twelfth grade
for the most part
we know what's out there i know what you
went through
of course you feel insecure about it i'm
just looking you at the face and saying
enough [__] that [__] sean it's over
there is no sixth grade [__]
donny picking on that anymore it's over
like
it is time right now to start the
process to flip it
be like yeah i got this thing yeah and
what you like like my big thing is like
anybody that makes you feel
inferior my big question to that [__]
face is
what about you like there is nobody
better than me and i want you to feel
that way too
yeah that's what because i'm almost i
have such a big personality
and the reason like like i do a lot of
videos like me when i go show houses but
i never show me
because i might when i look back at the
video i look back at like all my like
twitching like my my voice pauses
and that's like i like it nah i like it
it's unique i appreciate that it's true
and you have a good like graspy voice
it's kind of like that sexy dude what
you got bro you are who you are
not a priest unfortunately for you for
some people they can hide it because
it's inside it's in their brain
it's in their stomach you know it's
their religion but you didn't know they
don't look
the part bro you can't hide it
yeah so what the [__] are we doing here
if you can't hide it
own it put it on a pedestal and by the
way
you got a responsibility bro just like i
did i had such
mental happiness i was like [__] i like
subconsciously got into the world that
cat wrote the poem about i'm like i have
to give
bro there are little boys and girls
right now that have the same thing that
you have
they need you you know i don't even
think about it like that you're so stuck
in your
in your own like tunnel vision that's
right yeah you want to feel real good
get that first dm from the girl in
fourth grade from tick tock
that's like you're my hero because you
look so confident with yours
that it made me feel better today and i
walked into school and i told those
[__] girls [__] you
you wanna really get high you wanna you
know what feels way better than selling
a big home for a big commission
having a [__] child email you and
tell you that you made their life better
that's
that's 100 because i mean i i didn't
even know what i had it
just what was like too i didn't know
what i had what's funny is i found out i
had stress because
i watched an mtv show where it's like
i'm living with this and i was like i'm
living with tourette's and i was like oh
god
and this was me in middle school i was
like oh crap like i have that
and i didn't even know that because no
it wasn't like nothing mainstream
this like now thank god 2020 mental
health is very disgust but that wasn't
discussed when i was
like 14 years old i know
bro you won
most people work their whole life to
have something unique
you were gifted it stop thinking it's
bad
it's [__] good i'm being serious i
think it's cool no i know you are like
sitting here like man i wish i had that
[__] i'd [__] be like everybody would
know me
just because
i try to see in that perspective i
definitely i definitely do it's like
like you didn't do [__] to have this i
love when pretty people walk around like
they did something your parents had sex
at the right moment they happen to be
like what the [__] did you do the [__]
are you walking around here like you're
somebody you didn't do [__] you [__]
got lucky
i slash i got to be fair slash
you ate right you worked out like like
you know i'm not like
luck because i was just thinking i'm
like it's not true a lot of people
are born with the right kind of stuff
but like they didn't put in the work
i look better and i did [__] seven
nine years ago like i get it
like so none nonetheless where i'm going
with that
where i'm going with that is you need to
use this moment in your life you're so
lo i'm so
happy we're here at such a young age bro
it's [__] good yeah
i try to for what i know the next person
but what's going on
i always say when up you know when
opportunity you know meets it like
like luck is basically when you get the
opportunity again there's something so
like did you say with these small house
like i literally take anybody who needs
to help a real estate
i do like nothing's too small or too big
for me and like i said i hope
anybody watching can know that you could
be in a field like literally i deal with
people every day
and not let like i don't let it stop me
i'm hungry
so i just hope that everybody's seeing
this i just need i think
like everybody including myself we all
need perspective tweaks
all the time i think that's what i'm
good at perspective tweaks i think you
leave here and say
man garyvee might be right this might be
a unique thing
that people think is cool of course
there'll be a lot of people that are
like nah but they're gonna be not anyway
you can't hide and then you show up and
like you're wasting your time by not
putting yourself out there
you're trying to hide it then they come
[__] half of them are like nah i'm
out and now you feel bad twice
just put it out in front that's what i
do there's a lot of people don't want to
do business with me i'm too intense i'm
too hardcore
i have too many different perspectives
but i just put out in front this way i
never see them in the first place
they know what they're getting into when
they have a meeting with me
that's an example and the respect you
see you're wasting time sean
you just hide your [__] thing but
then they show up and they don't feel
comfortable with it
and that's why you've got half your
customers that you could show the house
or two to
and you didn't close because they
quietly wanted to be polite
like you know and just bounce and go
somewhere else because they're thrown
off by it
[__] them don't even let them come to
you don't let them come to you bro
damn yeah you're i mean i can't even
there's no rebuttal
there really is no rebuttal you're 100
right
and the fact that you can help 55 kids
have a much happier life
you got to do that's why you got to put
yourself out there
i appreciate it man i appreciate
definitely definitely appreciate it
if you're in south florida and you're
looking to well a lot of people are well
now it's all [__] up but i'll get
better again
i think you know this is just gonna be a
see-saw like [__] up in the east then
into the south then it's gonna be [__]
up yeah
you know like in november everyone's
gonna go back to miami so nonetheless
all right my man talk to you soon
appreciate it
by the way before we go to the next one
that
right there is for everybody like you
know like your nose
you you you you don't like the sound of
your voice
you don't like that you put on 15 pounds
during covid get the [__] out of here
everybody's got [__] everybody else
sucks
too you want to get real happy
everybody else sucks too
seth get in here do this with me let's
help them ready
one two three yeah one two three
everybody everybody why are you lagging
here we gotta do in unison just to get
in here all three of us
here we go ready ready i'm gonna go one
two three and i'm gonna
do it everybody's else sucks too ready
one
two three everybody
greatest hashtag of all time everybody
else
sucks too
i don't think anybody's better and
here's where it gets real good when you
get to this place
once you cross over and then realize and
you're not better than anybody
hear that wind the wind came right at
the right time see what just happened
i see you came at the right time
that all right let's go
hey gary how are you pretty good man how
are you doing
good lewis or louise luis luis such a
pleasure
yeah you too man super excited to be
here great to have you what can i help
you with
yes so uh i have two things in my mind
i'll give you a little background before
that
i'm from venezuela i moved to the u.s
four years ago for college i got a
scholarship in iowa
and i didn't even know where that was in
the map until i moved
so it was a crazy change for me but it
really changed my life because before
back home
i with the situation and everything i
was not motivated at all so i've learned
a lot in four years and uh
right now i moved to chicago two months
ago during the pandemic
i got a job when i graduated and uh it's
been great
and i guess i'd be lying you know i
always try to focus on
gratitude because you know i'm lucky to
be here already just the fact that i had
the opportunity to be in the u.s is
amazing
so i just try to focus on that but a lot
of you know knowing what happened in
venezuela over the last 25 years
because i like geopolitics
you you know that was some hardcore [__]
right like when you got here
were you taken aback by how many people
complained about dumb [__]
yeah because you were just so grateful
you're like you don't even get it
yeah exactly like i used to line up like
i wasn't even
one of the worst ones like i had a lucky
situation
so to say compared to most people back
home and i was still line up for food
sometimes and so when i got here
that really gave me a lot of perspective
so
that's huge for me and i guess so my
first question is that
you know knowing that my visa i guess i
get to work for a year here
technically and then i don't know what
will happen after that so how do you
deal with a situation i know like
you got to focus you're not in control
you're not in control
got to let go it was like that wind
moment a couple of minutes ago like
bro you're not in control you're talking
about something very real which is like
yo gary cool
trying to get the most out of this time
but in the back of my mind every night
when i'm sleeping in my dreams and my
subconscious i'm in the shower when i
brush my teeth i'm like [__] man
237 days 190 days and i'm gonna have to
go back and [__] this there's so much
opportunity here
but here's the thing you're young as
[__] there's opportunity all over the
world obviously i believe very much in
america america
going through a really tough time with
herself right now
in in looking at her warts her
shortcomings
but you know there's so much opportunity
still within that and
the framework still allows for so much
happiness if you focus on it if you look
for it
compared to many places around the world
including where you came from you know
you came from a regime and i came from a
regime
that you know really really isn't right
and really
has never worked historically so i think
that
i think the thing to think about is you
can't control it
that's just the way it is that's the
truth in the same way that if somebody
told you
you know what else you can't control
life if somebody said good news you got
a green card you're here forever but you
couldn't control that a tree fell on
your head when the wind blew right like
like once you start understanding you
can't control it what you can control
is your perspective of gratitude in any
situation
right you can control coming back to
venezuela being very frustrated but
saying nah i got that year in america
and i learned these things and i'm going
to deploy it this way or this way or
[__] this i'm going to [__] singapore
or
[__] this i'm going to i'm going to
apply for 800 visas around the world
because i don't want to be here but i'll
be anywhere
or you know there's just a million
things or you know and so
people dwell on [__] they can't control
yeah that's true yeah i guess
awesome uh real quick another thing um
so uh during
you know i think march you know when
quarantine was starting and everything
uh i mean my friend we started you
talk about that you literally [__]
came to america you have this year
and you're like yeah this could be my
year and then [__] the world said
nah watch this cove it in your mouth you
know like
[__] you know like but go ahead you
and your buddy started uh
yeah so uh my roommate from college and
i we started a youtube channel
um right before everything started so we
just spent quarantine editing
you know i kind of learned to edit
myself as well love and uh
so i'm just right now with the job i
have here i actually really like it
and i'm super invested in it so i
haven't had time i guess to
focus on the youtube channel as much so
what do you think about you know
i know consistency is super important
with content and i want to have a
platform long term
you know that's a long term goal of mine
to just have a platform because i know
what content can do like the impact i
follow you like
you and a channel called yes theory like
they they really i take my motivation
for you guys
and i know how much it can impact people
so i want to have that in the future
so what do you think about that like
consistency but maybe more in the long
term
maybe like not releasing all the time uh
videos but more like a month
once a month yeah listen i think i think
less at bats give you less opportunity
but if you're not capable of putting out
content every day you know
then you're not capable i mean there's a
lot of things i'm not capable of you
know like
i'd like to get a six-pack but like
habits aren't
strong and i know what to do every day
but
it's just not there and so like i will
always push people to do content daily
because i think a lot of people don't
stretch themselves there's a lot of
things i'm doing now with my like
you know workouts that i never thought i
could do but i can do i just needed mike
vicanti and jordan saya to push me
um so i feel like i push people but then
there's certain things i'll never be
able to do and that's okay too and so
i'm okay with that but just remember
every day that you're not putting out
something
is a day that you're not getting an
opportunity for something to happen
yeah that makes sense and
i see somebody put quality over quantity
and my question is always like
what about both and who's judging the
quality i think one of the reasons you
might not be putting it out is you're
judging the quality
which really is insecurity right and so
that's the [__] i'm trying to kind of
like work on with everyone
definitely i spent a lot of time trying
to perfect the videos before
but it's your subjectiveness and then
you put it out and then there's the
audience and i have
i have too much humility i have too much
respect for the audience and i actually
think a lot of people
who go for perfection disrespect the
audience and then they put out the video
and it doesn't do well
and they literally say [__] like these
[__] don't get it i'm like no no
you don't get it [__] and by the
way that person was for the guy who said
his daughter just said stop
using bad words and i'll say to that
lovely young lady i apologize but this
is how i [__] communicate
you see all right thanks so much man
let's keep it going
hey gary what's good bro i'm so excited
right now
it's good to have you here what's your
name uh i king hi king great name
uh first i i want to take this first i
can really thank you because
i discovered you actually back in
october um i was listening to some
mashup of motivational videos and i
heard you say something about
people have the audacity to uh talk
about hustle and they want to live a one
percent life
but you don't want to sit and and
actually put the work in
and i was like oh i i gotta go in the
credits figure out who's talking on this
video and then i started voice matching
the names
that i heard and then i stumbled across
you um so i've been listening to you
since october i didn't
really start hearing you until kovid
when you when i stumbled across to you
with garyvee
um so i just want to say thanks because
you've really helped me
to look at life in a little bit more
positive way be less hard on myself
less judgmental okay um
so my question is about linkedin okay
i'll give you a little bit of context
real quick before i go into that
question please um
so um so my background is my stepfather
he
was so he pulled me and my siblings out
of school we were really young like four
and five years old
he basically put this fear in the in us
that the
everyone in the world is trying to kill
us that um
he's the only person that can protect us
like he's our guardian angel
he didn't let us go outside alone um our
lives
ran like that huh it was some dark [__]
yeah some really really dark stuff and
our lives ran like that until
about like i was 22 um
yeah thank you um so 22 comes
you know please come in arrest him
whatever
um then life begins you know and this is
you know four years later you know
you kind of got to grow up really fast
18 years lost and
you know no social interaction i lost i
king this is important
perspective tweaks not lost you know not
lost
like in a lot of ways you've gained
strengths that none of us will ever
understand
in a lot of ways you've been given
insecurities and fears that none of us
will ever understand
but just like sean earlier with
tourette's like
this is where people really make a huge
mistake in my opinion
they don't realize that their uniqueness
is a strength i
working my through my entire adults
adolescence gave me incredible strengths
that everybody can see
it also created shortcomings with
certain parts of my relationship craft
because
i didn't mature in areas that everybody
else did you know
for and so like i think it's important
to understand that
that i just want to make sure that you
don't fully go into the place
that so many have gone into which will
lead to unhappiness through your 80s
little in your 20s
not lost just a different path
okay and some unique strengths that
maybe we haven't unders
haven't discovered or uncovered yet some
unique strengths my man
yeah thank you keep going um so yeah so
give my you know get my ged go do a
vacation at school get a job doing that
for three years as a medical assistant
you didn't go to school you were
homeschooled
home schooled technically but no real
course material or just
kept in the house basically like jailed
in the house
keep the cage yeah pretty much and how
like like some of the [__] that you see
in the documentaries right like that one
documentary those boys like like that
kind of stuff right
yeah so what the outside world for you
was tv and
did you even have tv and internet did
you like cut that off that was that was
it was only antenna um tv cable was cut
off
and then that was extremely regulated so
the only television was like sesame
street
stuff like that even as we grew up into
you know our adolescent years
yeah um intense [__] man i have a lot of
empathy for you keep going
so um i got my ged driver's license
tried to adapt
um was medical assistant for three years
kind of got bored with that
um then i decided you know i'm from i
was originally from south jersey
yeah atlanta i grew up atlantic city
love it inside there yeah so
um i just i have family here in florida
they have some great hearts they're like
come down here if you ever you know
want to you know change of pace and
stuff like that so i'm down here with
them right now
um i got into health insurance selling
health insurance little did i know the
like the orange season for that pass so
i came in the off season
and covered hit so definitely slowed
things down
i'm i'm working you know part-time job
getting a full-time job
and then at the same time trying to work
on my health insurance
because i know when open enrollment
comes around it's going to be great
now my question is i i'm
created a linkedin profile of course um
so i can try and get into the
professional
world a little bit and one gentleman
that had connected with
he was like i'm very careful of who i
let into my into my networks
that's already a very bad statement okay
keep going
um yeah he was like um i'm very careful
who i let into my network
and um what else do you have to offer me
to me besides health insurance what out
of value can you bring to me
and it kind of hit me at a little bit
it really stopped me for a little bit
that day and i was like
i don't really have any other value i
went to his profile he had
a couple of different companies he
worked for different positions he held
uh if you went to a couple like a couple
college degrees
so that was a kind of bit of my length
my question about linkedin
i feel like i get intimidated with that
everybody else
sucks too let me let me tell you about
this dude tell that dude to come and see
me
because i'm gonna [__] destroy his
[__] insecurity he's a piece of [__]
for doing that okay
give a [__] what degrees he had or where
he worked [__] that dude
it's not better than me [__] him
okay the you know
what you know that's tapping into the
[__]
insecurity of uh that [__] i want to
punch that [__] dude in the face
yeah don't let somebody don't like
listen you grew up in
first of all the level of strength that
you have is like [__]
earth-shattering i can do do you
actually understand
the fact that you're this functional
like speaks to like an
incredible like you i promise you
i don't know that guy i've know you for
four minutes
on with every ounce of my soul
i know that you're 17 trillion times
stronger than that dude
he has created an insecure framework
and you have flourished
out of garbage with pure strength
i mean that or do you think i'm wrong
like when you hear that or you're like
yeah gary
were you like what do you mean or are
you like nah
i tend to always put myself on the back
burner you know because that's the way i
was raised
like that's like my stepfather would be
like you're here to start you know the
only reason you're around is to serve me
and to help me and my priorities is what
comes first
but you know you know
obviously it's your framework but you
know that's not true right
i know it's not true what you have to be
careful to is you're going to gravitate
towards it
yeah they're a partner in life whether
that business scenario my fear for you
is you're going to go towards that kind
of situation
yeah and i'm working i'm i'm working
hard
to consciously try and recorrect that
i can tell which is why it's so [__]
awesome
no thank you you know most people don't
even realize they're doing it most
people don't realize they're going into
abusive relationships
because that was the framework they
don't even see it they don't have the
tweak
you have you're so woke for such a
young man and just so freshly out of
that cocoon
it's it's actually incredibly inspiring
to me
yeah thank you you're actually a
blessing you know what you've done for
me on this show
you've made all the [__] tens of
thousands of other people that are
watching this right now
take a step back and stop complaining
about that they aren't going to the gym
as often as they used to
like you've put things in perspective
for thousands of people right now who
cry about what they had or their their
parent didn't do this or didn't buy me a
new car
or they you know like you just [__]
like pierced people through the [__]
soul
yeah like
yeah i think the tactical question about
linkedin is garbage the bigger question
is
you dude you're strong
like i king's a good name for you
you you you kind of know you're strong
right i
i do see it sometimes um there and i
acknowledge it and then there are the
times of course you know you can't
always
acknowledge it and and and be at yours
you have siblings that were in that i do
yeah three three sisters
and and of course i'm sure they've
they've him some of them are handling it
differently than you have right
yeah we're all remarkably strong i would
say
we're not we're not all like knit tight
like that
um but we yes we are processing it
differently
yeah and some need you know like that
would make sense to me like
i even am sitting and trying to put
myself in that scenario i might go off
and just be like yo i'm gonna be like
with me for a minute you know like that
would make sense to me
that's really good dna thank god for
that
yeah sure um so
so i shouldn't let that bother me if i'm
trying to put content out on linkedin
whether you know people want to crush my
credentials or anything like that
hi king the fact that you showed up in
the episode that we established the
hashtag
everybody else sucks too is the greatest
[__] thing of all time
of course you shouldn't let it bother
them remember this there's only a very
small group of people on linkedin
that are on paper or in theory more
successful than me
i'm telling you right to your [__]
face as a human that you're a [__]
man
so if you're gonna take other people's
validations there's only about
a small group left on linkedin that can
trump
me you know in that status what have you
so good news you can tell the other 99
to go [__] themselves
there you go there's a little gift i'm
coming to your face that you're the
[__] guy
that i want to be friends with you that
i'm like sitting here like should i hire
this dude like
i'm about you so if you're in a
framework where you take other people's
opinions as value which by the way i
don't think you should
[__] my opinion about you you're not
people but
if you're in that place because we all
go through it
next week when you feel it be like well
[__] this person garyvee said i'm the
best that they suck compared to garyvee
if that's what you want my thing is i
want you to get real quiet
talk about cutting out you know you
unfortunately took
you know you know it's so crazy it's so
emotional how i just got when you just
said yes sir because i'm just like
imagining your [__] life and it just
[__] makes me want to
rip that [__] person apart
on the flip side i'm so grateful that
you have the dna of this level of
strength that would have broke
so many people now bro you're good
you're real good
like when you're you're most down please
go back and watch this clip
hear those words hear them from somebody
that [__] knows [__]
i have intuit i was blessed with [__]
intuition juices that
be illegal one day like you're good bro
you're [__] good
[__] that dude the [__] audacity he
doesn't let people into his [__]
linkedin
get the [__] out of here with that
[__] [__] loser
he's just a junior version of the
[__] evil your stepdad tried to do
yeah scared people do scared things
that's true i feel bad for those two
i know that's something i've been
hearing you say and it's really changed
my perspective a lot instead of being
angry
probably having some empathy for them
100 they're broke as [__]
they're [__] broken we're not broken
and you you got time too you got your
whole [__]
life i was feeling like i was behind
because
i heard you but when you were like oh
when i left my dad's wine store at 30
something
and i built you know vaynermedia [__] i
mean carl sanders made a kentucky fried
chicken happen in his [__] 60s or 70s
yeah you're awake off at 40.
are you kidding me [__] me i'm like one
tiny example
there's only and by the way back to
success how about the 63 year old that
[__] finally went to therapy
and got happy how about the 59 year old
that finally figured out actually my
mom's a piece of [__] so [__] her
i'm not living for her validation
anymore i'm gonna live like this and at
got happy for 20 years and lived life
instead of when 84 always [__] up in
that scenario
[__] me there's millions out there doing
it yeah
can i ask one more one more thing yeah
so i was listening to one of your four
d's um yesterday when i was at work
um and you had mentioned something that
you can
you can't grow your chest you can't
build a chest and it's something that
you never would be able to do because
it's not your body type
actually bro honestly it started
starting to come out it started
you know what's funny though when you
have no chest muscle
i was like going at it for like two
years i'm like oh yeah and of course i
kind of knew because you see those thin
boxers they don't have the biggest
chests but like i
i logically knew i was being a little
bit more tongue-in-cheek
but i'll tell you this you [__] need
that foundation like now
it's growing exponentially because i can
actually feel it because i have one so
the
so my form is better because you know
jordan was like i was doing this one
thing he's like feel it i'm like what
the [__] he talking about
how can you think i don't know am i like
doing it right like so anyway
i was a little tongue in cheek with it
yeah so my question was um
i don't know why this got weird maybe it
was the way i said it this man is not 40
years old
he's 22 what are you 22 you said 26. 26.
which he looks great for 26 but
nonetheless keep going yeah so
i'm on my instagram i'm like fitness and
health um inclined
so and lately what i've been doing is
like tutorials on different exercises
and stuff like that would it
i wanted to put up some chest specific
tutorials
you guys tag you and i'll show you
dustin
and i was hoping you can follow me at
that point i just don't want to ask for
a follow-up
about something i appreciate you not
asking for the follow
up but you've earned it with your
incredible
humanity here rise body i
highly expect and
desperately ask that this man's 409
becomes 4009
in the next 30 minutes boom solid
i started 296 today i know you say don't
not follow followers and likes but
listen no don't let that be your
affirmation but yeah bro i like your
chest i see it
good [__] okay listen to me
you're a [__] blessing you can really
help a lot of people by the way
i would mix in some of your real life
story into your content
you can help a lot of kids yeah i'm
working on it
good i appreciate you gary thank you you
got a king
seth you picked a good one
good [__] right that was amazing yeah
i his his i king that's tough bro
i admire that dude me too it's
incredible
everybody thank you for watching please
please please please please please share
this
up uh looking forward to next week it's
good to be back with tea with garyvee
i just saw my dad walk by uh wine text
winetext.com if you buy wine at all
you mean the world to me if you signed
up the best service in the world
big offer today coming sports cards
followed by content of that google go to
google right now and put sports cards
garyvee
consume that content there's a three
hour marathon on youtube
uh seth dustin let's do the sports card
uh let's make a little trailer for the
sports card episode i want to get a lot
of people they're gonna make money
and they're gonna get happy happiness i
love you go to twitter right now
go to twitter right now and tell me what
you thought about the show see you
i love you bye